I can't help but wonder,
had Harrison Butker taken a moment to shout out women
for their amazing careers they were about to have,
or for the volunteer work they would do,
or for the businesses they were going to open,
he wouldn't be facing the backlash he's facing right now.
He said, I know my wife would say
her life really began the day she opened her business,
or the day she started helping her patients as a doctor,
or the day she started writing her book.
Nobody would be mad at him.
We probably wouldn't have heard any controversy about the speech,
or we would be supporting it.
And that is because we see the value in those.
We know that those things contribute to our society,
to our world. But when it comes to things like stay at home mothers,
homemakers, housewives,
those things you have been conditioned to think are not valuable.
Why, you never hear anybody say,
you can be so much more than just a lawyer.
You can be so much more than just a senior vice president.
But as women, we hear that all the time about being wives and mothers.
So many people,
women especially,
have been conditioned to see the role of mother,
of homemaker, of housewife as degrading.
So they put it down here.
So when someone comes along and says, women,
this is the greatest thing you can do,
they look down here and go,
you mean way down There, homemaker, mom.
And they're offended and they lose their minds, because, how dare he?
But for a lot of us,
we see that role up here,
so we aren't offended.
When somebody recognizes that,
that's great. It just seems to go very unnoticed by our culture.
And when we finally have someone who has a big voice
and who has a big platform
recognize that and recognize that work,
we cancel him.
People, women,
usually women who are supposed to be on our side,
they say, no,
you are not to praise those women.
Sure, you can celebrate women for any other thing in the world,
but not that.